Ukraine Although I seem to be telling me in the
evening, we are not very fast,
because the commander is
laid up to the commander-in-chief, I have no doubt that
maybe it was not our rocket wallpaper our
missile attack
behind the positions,
but it can be assumed that Ukraine
was honestly spent for a month now, respecting the right to
show the face  not over But can I
seem acutely accurate exhibition Why is
she my slime well, I like it
fairly fairly brought the group
we my rights I keep saying
who is there
it will be clear
that we are all partners we are all partners from
Russia
public and should not be
direct direct
and we have  I’ll show up
here more often
Yes, yes, we’re not such signals I’m
already saying that I said that on 9 we
propane
publicly blame Russia publicly
in our understanding of
Polish and American experts